So the first question son, which was
asked in your NEET 2013, was asked in 23, what kind of
question was yours, was it a female column type question
and what was it related to? Yours was related to ECG,
so this question
should not be wrong for anyone, right, there are so many
students.  Everyone should be correct
that what will the P wave represent? What will the Q
wave represent?
What is the RS complex and what is the meaning of T wave? Just now you have
solved it, so
everyone will tell the correctness right now. So
here child, your correctness.  The answer will
also be yes, that will be your D option, what will
P wave do, what will it do for depolarization of
atria, if you talk about K wave, then
what is yours, that is the big A
there, what will be your beginning of
systole, what will be QRS
complexation  Off ventricular
ejection will make the ventricle go right.